let's not to is all fee geisel about
this from the association of German
chambers of commerce and industry
Europe's shift to the right let's start
with that what does that mean for
business in your words a problem because
business and drew in Germany is more and
more international and international
business is not only international
business in function of claims but also
in function of employees and the tech
sector in Saxony silicon Saxony I
mentioned it before employs 50,000
people I mean they're the types of firms
that could just up and go at any time
and employ someone else somewhere else
in the world because they're the tech
sector I mean a lot of that stuff goes
on line and in the cyber world and
doesn't have to be done in Saxony yes
but you must say that they are also very
dependent of qualified qualified
workforce and you don't find everywhere
in the world the same level so we are
quite good in Germany concerning our
qualification level but are they getting
enough qualified workers here because
the skills shortage is a problem in
Germany isn't it yes it's where my face
yes but skills shortage is not only a
problem in Germany if you go elsewhere
you have a lot of workforce but not only
automatically skills workflow thurs ok
so the migrants do play a big part there
I mean and some of the migrants that
have been coming to Germany do have
skills and could be integrated into the
German workforce but then there's the
language barrier isn't there yes at the
moment you must say we don't if we look
at refugees coming in the last year we
do not really know which kind of
qualifications and which kind of
vocational training they have it is not
really very well analyzed already but
one thing is clear the German labor
market needs people from abroad because
we can't we come out and we kind of
can't compensate our demographic change
problem by internal potentials but what
happens when an employer doesn't want
someone from abroad when an employer
does want a german it depends also
always the branch but i think there are
many many branches
are really dependent to be more
multicultural and more diverse employees
okay well let's have a look at an
initiative of yours in March your
organization the association of German
chambers of commerce and industry
launched an initiative known as
companies integrate refugees the aim
being to connect firms with each other's
share experience offer legal advice and
of course get migrants into the
workforce at last count 670 businesses
had joined big and small a clear signal
to the rest of the world I guess you
could say of Germans willingness to help
those fleeing persecution and war in the
Middle East and Africa would you agree
we started in March so it could be
always better we always could be still
the beginning it's still the beginning
and I see that them we find more and
more companies who are very interested
in integration things and who are very
interested in in the practical questions
how can we integrate refugees or
migrants but it's not something we are
Germany not really an integration
country our migration country and
therefore we have there are not so many
blueprints and to how you get that how
you do that but what are some of the
right things that employers are doing to
manage to integrate migrants we've had
lots of examples I think we have to
develop in Germany somehow diversity
cultures in the companies but we also
have to deal with a lot of it especially
if you look at refugees we have to deal
with a lot of bureaucratic and Agnes
administrational questions at the moment
because it's very new for us and we are
confronted we are faced with the
situation we are not fully in at the
moment and but companies have I would
say six problems they want to know how
they get in contact with with refugees
with migrants they want to know how they
can employ them how they can overcome
the language barrier which is really
very hard in Germany because we are so
German and they have also the question
how can we prepare our people who is
already in the company how can we how
can we implement
diversity culture these are one of the
big questions companies has a moment at
the moment to to to answer and very
briefly just your advice to companies
who were struggling or worse to this
don't want to do this you don't want to
integrate migrants what's your advice
and X try try it out try it out and not
be don't be so cautious and so um don't
be courageous do it okay a lot of
companies has really good experience
with that try try and try again so if
you guys don't thank you very much for
coming in today